foreign
we're going to start this hour with
Ashley in Jacksonville Florida hi Ashley
how are you
hi I'm good how are you better than I
deserve what's up
so I wanted to talk through an issue my
husband he recently purchased I guess
it's been about a year he purchased a 72
000 car
um and we are not in a financial place
to have been able to afford that car
he's currently the only one working and
as of now I believe we still owe sixty
two thousand dollars on the car and
obviously that's not including interest
um so our finances kind of look at the
moment he's paying 1200 a month for the
car
not including insurance I know
um and then for rent we pay about 1500.
so there's been like a very big struggle
obviously between trying to keep up with
that and then saving and trying to just
kind of invest in our future so
obviously horrible horrible decision but
I'm hoping there's a way that we can
kind of get back from this
did he do this without telling you
um we we actually just got married last
year and I believe it's kind of a
terrible story I'm not even gonna say
it's a funny story it's not he had a car
that he just completely paid off
so he had that car perfectly good
condition and then he decided he wanted
to get an SUV which he purchased for
about 32 000 I think and then the
dealership emailed him saying hey we
have a great deal for you you can bring
that new car and trade it in and upgrade
to this electric car that he's been
wanting so he did not he briefly
mentioned that to me and from what he
told me it sounded like it was kind of
going to be an equal trade maybe he'd be
paying a little bit more that's what it
sounded like to me so he went did that
took care of it and then it wasn't until
a few months ago that I fully understand
like the gravity of what had actually
happened but all of that occurred before
you were married
um like during during the time like
before I mean he didn't he did not do
this while you were at the altar so
there is no during
yeah it was before or after you were
married you were legally married and
then he did this
okay yeah and then of course when I
questioned them about like what was
possibly going through his mind he
honestly didn't really have an
explanation and just said it was an
extremely stupid decision that he just
couldn't
um take back and now we found something
we agree on okay yeah but why can't he
just go sell this car today what do you
mean you can't take it back so the
reason why he's not able to sell it is
because the highest amount he's even
getting for this car now is forty
thousand dollars and we still owe like
65 or 63 000. who said
um he's talked to a few dealerships
about this yeah he's not good at this
yeah we're talking private party here of
course if you go to a dealership they're
going to give you a card who made who's
the maker
yeah
it's like an electric Kia seventy two
thousand dollars for a Kia yeah I know I
know
not not okay he paid 72 000 for it when
um this was in
April of 2022
. and you're telling me one year and it
dropped in half 32 000 drop yeah no I'm
not buying it he's justifying like I
should keep this car lot talk okay
because I'm just I think I'm calling BS
this is a guy I don't want to sell the
car
and he's trying to make this deal out
worse than this but let's just pretend
it's 50 and not 40 which it could be
okay all right we still got a uh a
twelve thousand dollar hole right and
what does he make
um about 90. okay
and do you have any other debt
um no major debts just a couple uh
smaller dots on credit cards under under
two thousand dollars
okay that's your only debt other than
your home do you own a home
no we don't we're renting good okay so
he makes 90. he owes 65 on a car 62. 62
on a car and when let's pretend you
could sell it for 50. okay
um and uh uh uh it's a Kia what
what sex a what
ev6 EVC they're running from as low as
46 but it quickly goes up to 50 plus
so you could definitely sell this thing
for 50 plus so I think your husband
called the same dealer that screwed him
the first time and asked them what did
they give him for it and they thought oh
we're going to get this guy again the
third time we're going to screw this guy
over yeah so 40 is below wholesale
so if you put the thing on the market on
trader.com or search something like that
and sold it yourself
uh the market value private sale is
closer is in the 50s like I suspected
okay because the numbers you were giving
us were just unbelievable that the car
even a Kia would lose that much in one
year it's just unbelievable so all right
so he's not good at this or he doesn't
want to sell it one of the two or both
so we're going to sell it for 50 and
we're going to borrow 12 to cover the
difference
from your local bank or your credit
union
and you probably need to borrow about
you don't have do you have any money
um not much saved up that's not much
um like
four to five thousand dollars good okay
so I would borrow I would borrow 10 and
buy a five thousand dollar car
and borrow 10 and be ten thousand
dollars in debt and we'll call that debt
stupid tax
yeah which is what I have to pay when I
do something stupid
okay and you guys have a rule from this
point forward in your marriage we do not
make financial decisions without both of
us being involved and being in agreement
oh yeah I made that very very clear no
you didn't because you did this after
you were married
I know well now I made it Ashley from
today forward you are involved with the
money in this marriage yeah you were a
part of there's no more I didn't know
and he is too and he is too you know so
um both of you have a vote and both of
you decide but what I would do is I
would borrow ten thousand dollars I
would buy a five thousand dollar card
for cash and I would sell this car and
then I would pay off the ten thousand
dollars with your 90 income and no
payments if no payments but the ten
thousand dollars and your couple of low
credit cards that you need to cut up
today
and uh we're gonna help you because you
guys are getting started on a rough foot
here on a sore foot from kicking each
other and um we're gonna put you into
Financial Peace University I'll pay for
it if you will both promise to go when
you talk to Austin you're on hold with
him right now